I have been doing the carnivore diet. There are many testimonials of it, helping to hospitalize as well as cancer for five weeks.
I've done well on it and have no intestinal or other symptoms while on it.
Last week for about four days before the diarrhea, so the person asked another question that they had diarrhea.
I ate cheese. I've had no dairy for about a year before this. My carol thinks that diarrhea is just my gallbladder overreacting to all the fat with the additional cheese.
And it will subside if I stop cheese on Sunday.
I've also had three rounds of cutrudo with my keyboard and the last cutrudo was early in November. Could the tear diarrhea be a side of another autoimmune disease popping up like colitis or something else?
Could this happen long after the last dose?
Well, I answered the last question first. Yes, it could happen long after the last dose. Well, I should really say
that the symptoms of it could show after the last dose, long after the last dose.
So if you do have colitis, we have antibodies too.
So colitis is not an autoimmune disease, but it's inflammation and colitis.
That could still cause an autoimmune issue.
But testing for antibodies would be really the thing to do. However, I would look at, I don't know that I would completely agree with your other doctor that the diarrhea is your gallbladder overacting.
That's not going to really give you diarrhea for several days.
If your gallbladder is contracted, it's courting out bile into the wadden, which is going to digest fat more.
So when you eat fatty food like dairy, your bile is going to be secreted from the gallbladder in greater amounts.
That will help break down the dairy, but that isn't going to cause diarrhea.
However, if you have antibodies, if you have antibodies in different foods, I could be able to have KCD antibodies.
Absolutely, you could get this reaction.
So if you were contacting me and you were not a cancer patient, you had no history of keeping true to use.
And you said you had diarrhea and it was tied to, maybe tied to dairy.
Maybe tied to the carnivore diet that you were doing.
The first thing I would do is do a Syrex 3x, Syrex 4 and Syrex 10 on you, those are rates.
So that would look for antibodies to food. So when you got in a inflammatory process going on and you're got you want to dig into your own why.
Now, if you're like, hey, I don't have the money to do those tests, well, then you could do a food elimination.
I'm not sure I wouldn't, I don't know how much cheese you ate earth was just a little cheat on your diet.
But having cancer, you want to stay away from cheese for sure.
So you want to stay away from dairy for sure going at a food elimination diet would be another thing to do.
Like I said, just going off to see if it clears up, see if it calms down.
If it does calm down, you could cut a say, maybe that's it, maybe I have antibodies to KC.
Certainly going on, keep true to ramps up your immune response and you're going to be more prone to develop a lot of immune disease, which are also more prone to create antibodies against foods that you're eating too.
So that's a possibility. So only one way to check that is to do a.
Okay, everyone test, which would be a Syrix array.
Three X.
All right.